welcome back to CBS this morning and
welcome back to Nora lady from the East
I know it didn't want to miss this I've
hooked her interview with Secretary Mike
Pompeo
I'm sure he's jealous that you're here
okay well now see Mike Pompeo to
Sebastian exactly that's what we do
yin-yang and what's your position on
North Korean people magazine called
Sebastian Maniscalco the comedian's
comedian but he describes himself simply
as an opinionated observer very funny
one though he delivers his unique take
at sold-out shows on subjects like his
own italian-american family and the
absurdity of modern technology take a
look
if you come from immigrants they don't
play around with the work okay no Morgan
says up an 8 8 years old these people
put me to work I don't know what was
going on I was watching cartoons on a
Saturday my father walked in the living
room he's okay
go start a business now
a lot of people like uber uber X what is
that what is it
it's like hitchhiking with your phone I
got friends that brag about how green
they are you go to their house they're
like look at the look at the lightbulbs
in my home I'm kitchen saving a 53% on
my electricity because I got green light
balls I go yeah I can't see you it's
performing this fall and winter and
shows across North America that includes
four shows in January at New York's own
Madison Square Garden three of the
18,000 seats shows are already sold out
his wildly successful stand-up tour it's
called stay hungry that's also the title
of his best-selling autobiography it's
published by gallery books an imprint of
Simon & Schuster which is owned by CBS a
very long introduction but for you thank
you for coming fashion I don't know I
think being an immigrant myself
there's something about you talking
about your immigrant family that
resonates with so many people across the
country whatever their background why do
you think that is it's the shared
experience it's the family I think
sometimes in comedy the family is like
underserved and I kind of bring the
family to to the focal point of my act
especially my dad growing up in this
kind of old-world home where you know
some of some of the stuff that I heard
growing up with a yeah I mean my father
is you know it's just he's opening up
envelopes and I saw one of the envelopes
at the house and I said Salvatore non
Maniscalco I go what is this he goes the
application asks me for my middle name I
put none I think people kind of relate
to you talk about your Italian roots
this is what I thought was funny you
said every Italian thinks he's gorgeous
because his mom tells him so everyday
you grew up in a house like that where
they really gave you such high
self-esteem especially when I first did
my first
shot it was it was like a beautiful
eight eight and it was eight eleven and
I did an eleven oh and my mother's like
you got to send this out this is
beautiful yeah I grew up with really
really big characters as for parents and
and it's it's it's part of my comedy and
you're married to a woman out of your
league totai your own admission I'm not
saying that you said that you're easily
annoyed by people yes yeah my wife is
more of the kind of puppy dog in the
relationship I'm more south from the
south loves people you know open door
policy you want to come over to my house
sleep over that's fine but I'm more like
there's just a lot of people at the
house that I don't know and you
mentioned the cat thing as a comedian
though you're out there you're fully
facing all the time is that why you have
to be a cat because you're basically got
a recharge for your show yeah I don't
know I'm Simon in front of people so
much too performing when I come home I
like to kind of just be with my family I
don't like to have a lot of people
around me I don't know I just that's the
way I've always been a pretty much of a
shy guy growing up but I swear I won't
quite leave I was not the class clown I
was the guy in the back looking at the
class counts I'm saying just sit down
yeah it's not funny but yeah I've always
been kind of reserved and and just the
observer but now you're at Madison
Square Garden crazy your first time
three sold-out shows I saw you at Jerry
Seinfeld show I'm sitting yesterday
saccas what going who is that guy he's
hilarious and so you become friends now
with the Seinfeld and I wonder what
that's like me growing up will you
admired him and now you're friends and
now you're Madison Square Garden doing
something that your family goes what is
this you're doing comedy
yeah Jerry Seinfeld there's been a great
great friend to me over the last four
years he put me on his show comedians
and cars and that's crazy i watch this
guy growing up and now we're
Los Angeles in a 69 Camaro and it's nuts
it's just one of those things where I'm
really enjoying all these different
things that are happening to me and I
don't take it for granted and these guys
like Jerry Seinfeld is real it really
helped me out I can't wait to see how
you include us in your routines thank
you I know did you see your doppelganger
over here much older man let's go
cheering you on all